We are back with my culinary bestie, Chef Pilar Valdes.
(audience cheering)
And she's here with a delicious meal
for your family that only takes seven minutes to make.
And to prove it to you,
we've got a timer set and we're gonna start the minute,
and I'm gonna say right now.
Pilar, what are we making today?
Okay. So we all have our go-to easy dinners, right?
We have our stir fries, our egg dishes, our sandwiches,
those are great options,
but sometimes you wanna jug things up a little bit.
So today we are making steamed mussels
in a butter and Dijon mustard sauce.
It's like restaurant quality,
but only in seven minutes, as you shall see.
(audience cheering)
I love restaurant quality in seven minutes.
So the first thing that we have in the pan over here,
is some olive oil and butter.
and that's nice and hot and melted,
and you're gonna throw in some chopped garlic and shallots,
and that's gonna be the base of your sauce.
So you're gonna give that a good saute.
You want a medium to high heat,
'cause again, seven minutes, here we go.
Season that little salt and pepper.
That's a little salt.
Salt.
Pepper.
Yeah.
I love that, so that's gonna go,
and then you're gonna mix your white wine Dijon mustard.
How easy is that?
Give that a little good whisk.
I love a whisk.
Mini whisk at that, and you're gonna pour it into the pan.
So what's gonna happen there,
as soon as you pour it into the pan
it's gonna infuse with the garlic and shallots,
and it's gonna stop the cooking so it's not gonna burn.
That's gonna come up to a boil, Drew.
I would throw the lid on there so it goes faster.
And while we're waiting for that to come up to boil,
can you throw actually the bread in the toaster oven?
I sure can.
Thank you.
Now, I love the way people cut bread,
because it makes a huge difference
in the pleasure and interaction of the sandwich.
Am I gonna cut it this way?
Like flat and open? Or do you wanna cut it pieces?
You could do that.
I'm also like a throw it in the oven,
and then tear it so it's nice and crusty.
Also saves some time.
I think if you do it on L1 Drew, that's gonna be fine.
So my sauce over here is coming up to a boil,
and I'm gonna throw in those mussels, Drew.
Okay? Because these are gonna take maybe
three to five minutes to cook fully,
and you know the mussels are steamed
when they fully open.
So Drew, we're gonna throw in your mussels.
I'm ready.
Cover it.
Give that a good shake around,
and then pop the cover on.
And they're gonna steam for about three to five minutes.
So while they're steaming,
your bread is toasting and let's chat mussels.
'Cause I think a lot of home chefs get a little intimidated
about using mussels,
and I really don't think people should be,
because they're incredibly simple to use and cook.
(audience laughing)
I can't believe I'm actually seeing you chop herbs.
I know, I'm so excited.
This is probably like the one dish where I'm like,
"Okay I'm gonna bring my knife to the party."
Pilar usually tears her herbs by hand
and feels very sacred about not damaging thy herb
with too much knife work.
It's so true.
So quick note about the mussels, really not intimidating,
great product to use, great source of protein and nutrients.
And they're actually one of the top choices
in terms of sustainability and affordability.
So definitely keep that in your mind.
You wanna make sure right before you use them,
you give them a good rinse.
And sometimes the mussels will come with the little beard,
which is these like tendra-like things,
and you're just gonna pull this off really easily.
And I feel like for shopping for mussels,
the most critical thing,
you want them to smell like really fresh and clean.
Like they were just kissed by the ocean.
So just a little bit of saltiness.
And if any of the mussel shells are cracked,
you definitely wanna discard those, don't deal with this.
Actually, can I get a time check?
'Cause my mussels are feeling pretty open and cooked
over here.
So every time we say mussels,
I think people just need to-
I also think my muscles are feeling
a little flabby, actually.
(Pilar laughing)
So...
How are your mussels doing over there?
'Cause mine are open.
(audience and Drew gasping)
I mean...
Mine are open and perfect.
(audience clapping)
And I'm gonna give that probably another 30 seconds.
Yeah, me too.
Until all the mussels are fully open.
You don't wanna deal with any of the mussels
that remain closed or are cracked.
So just discard those.
Those would be not possible to eat.
Not great to eat, absolutely.
So that was 30 seconds.
Drew, do you wanna grab your bread?
It all smells very good right now.
Beautiful.
We just need more space.
Here.
Here, let me remove that.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
And then the final thing to do
with these mussels, actually look at that.
Mine are perfect.
Beauty. Perfect
A few more grinds.
(audience cheering)
Any salt?
No more salt.
So the mussels will have like an inherent salinity.
So they give off this sweetness and saltiness.
Inherent salinity.
Few grinds of black pepper.
And then a little bit of the freshly chopped parsley.
And you can actually serve straight from the pot
like this or,
shimmy it into your serving bowl.
Shimmying.
Look at all
that beautiful sauce.
Shimming.
Absolutely.
Oh my gosh, I have to tell you,
I've always wanted to make a dish like this.
And you just made it
all possible.
More parsley.
(audience cheering)
Crusty bread.
Cheers.
I love you.
(audience cheering)
Shall we?
Hell yeah.
Mmm.
So good.
You have to serve it with the bread,
'cause that sauce is just like-
Oh my God.
So delicious.
Pilar...
You're amazing.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com for the full recipe.
I love this dish,
and I love you.
(upbeat music)